and the concrete bunkers here to stop
people like you running trucks into this
really important here let's talk about
does Islam teach the kulagin has been by
Tony Robinson by Isis and be terrorists
all of them here they are coming in
saying it's now teaches terrorism Holly
Robinson degrees briefers degrees
degrees al-qaeda bin Laden said yes
exactly so now we're on the other side
the British public asked to go and kill
innocent Muslims there's four types
there's combatants yes so when you're in
the battlefield this goes will verbal
combatant combat is verbally attacking
each other for example when Nazi Germany
Hitler was committed to our country this
land we are to defend yes
so this
buttons yeah so for example as
combatants when the bakers were fighting
the Muslims they are combating
non-muslims number two is the ones who
have a treaty with the Muslims yeah so
what they do is traitor yeah they have a
treaty so what that means is at the time
I'll just show you guys an example this
isn't evidence that the Prophet Muhammad
fishermen and the Muslims lived in
harmony with the Jews and Christians and
this is the treaty bro let me tell you
what went wrong this agreement or lost
the Prophet Muhammed shall apply to the
migrants Croatia the cities of yesterday
who have accepted Islam and all such
people who are in agreement with the
above-mentioned bodies and side with
them in war
those who those who are the party of
this Agreement shall be treated as a
body separate from all those who are not
a part of this Agreement it is incumbent
on all the Muslims to help an exemption
prophetic treatment to the Jews who have
entered into an agreement with us you
reading from the Koran
no this is the treaty so this is an
agreement with the Jews and the Muslims
living together in harmony
the Jews are fending off any magic bunny
Haris Bunny rah rah rah rah rah
Odie's Jews yes who are a part of this
agreement and I don't want to win the
crowd I will be losing series viewers
shall adhere to the religion and the
Muslims today so they have their
religion we have our religion accepting
the religion matters the Muslims and the
Jews should be regarded as belonging to
a single party if any one from among
them commits an outrage or breaks a
promise or is guilty of a crime he
should deserve a punishment of his crime
the support and the branches of
above-mentioned tribes shall have the
same right as are enjoined by the
original branches everybody has the same
rights if a third community wages war
against the Muslims and the Jews they
will have to fight United they should
hate help each other mutually and there
should be mutual goodwill and
faithfulness
the Jews were last much longer not
nearly finished they do shall bear the
expenses of war and the Muslims this now
this is but at the time of the Prophet
Mohammed it's more holsters that you're
reading for what reason is this a treaty
and in Medina off with the Muslims and
the Jews
now today that raucous issue before has
been hijacked and you have people coming
in the historian you have claimed this
in the British Army killed five thousand
Nazis Oh
executed the Jews what caused them in
battle and they were killed and
slaughtered after the bone okay and our
government got the Nazis for the Jews
I'm not sure could always find an
offense to suggest that the Jews were in
any way shape or form
one second I never said no stripper to
the Jews to the tripping of the Nazis
you direct the compare what did the
Nazis do for your childhood
what did Nazis do
[Music]
it was funny he said he said the Nazis
killed the Jews yeah and also they
attacked Britain and other countries yes
kill the Jews kill try to kill the
British public to try and cultures thank
you yeah now I'm seeing these Jews that
were killed were they innocent or did
they commit something oh it was our war
crimes trial with Jews was there and by
new movie if I'm mistaken and another
banner
okay the Carrera haineko why did what
did they do if you don't know how will
you make you claims that you have no
idea of these charges no I just said you
killed seven choose okay okay okay
British people killed on the words
there's a context so if you don't know
it was right that Mohammed killed 700
years me trying to justify
Jews while you pass it around city seven
were killed but guess by who and this
supposed to perform a bit no problem I
need to receive Jews were innocent
people what do they do they broke the
treaty when the pages were coming to
attack the Muslims very good laughing
remember the Jews the treaty that I read
to you was an agreement between the
Muslims and the Jews most of the tribes
of the Jews accepted it and stuck by it
except three sub-tribes resub tribes
attempted to kill the Prophet Mohammed
two times two times they attempted for
getting a lecture here in conversation
thank you guys
two times they tried to attempt to kill
the Prophet assassinate him one by
throwing the Brooklyn him and secondly
trying to poison his food did the
perfect kill them
no he acts out that he should go bye-bye
if he was a bloodthirsty person who
stick to the UK has a treaty with
American and UK goes behind us and goes
to the Russians and says I'm gonna give
you weapons fight the US okay now we've
gone to another topic
now this topic is why are you jumping
around sorry sorry sorry this is a
little bit bored by your trailer it just
goes on I don't care about your tree you
know what when I look at the balustrade
and the concrete bunkers here to stop
people like you running trucks into into
something concrete bunkers here to stop
people like you running trucks into we
don't have this concrete we don't have
these concrete blocks because of
Buddhists because of Hindus
because the Christians because of Jesus
we have it because of Muslims your
religion sacks thank you we found out
you achieve bigger to come now of course
I
excuse me this is not rap battle we're
gonna put some bars and walk away I can
do okay much change in this boat okay
walk away hi I'm cute now what we're
gonna do is as you can see guys when
context is being brought you have an
emotional person you see this barrier is
here it's because of new Muslims because
of me because I'm the same as those who
run people over and then II was I hate
your religion
bla bla bla I walked off what happened
the discussion
I know use upset I have to cool down now
okay so can we have a discussion or
shoot no no you know why I'm the same as
biggest cooler I can say whatever life
no no no you can't there's freedom in
this hate speech
what's a speech a speech morning so like
I said I said I am the same as those
people who run people over if I said
that I was wrong
thank you and I admire your honesty and
I forgive you for that
so can we come to why the Jews were
killed
please go ahead okay okay
the way that I explain on camera jump
into you again
there was three tribes joined them tried
to assassinate the Prophet but they were
not successful in their wake so if the
Prophet wasn't one tribe through a
rocket Rock and another tried to poison
him but if the Prophet was a
bloodthirsty person he would have smoked
was a very bloodthirsty person he was a
turtle Oh Lord okay I think you need to
cut down on TV yeah you're watching too
much TV I'm sorry it's ridiculous I'm
giving you coaching so much I'm giving
you context while you're still carrying
on two of them tried to kill the Prophet
the Prophet exiled both of them the
Prophet had every right to kill them at
the instance place it exiled the third
one joins forces with the pagans to kill
them as Brinn what British people we
have an alliance with America if Britain
decides to go behind America and sell
weapons to Russia to attack USA what
would USA do I used to just mean that
Russia would then use I promised to
attack America yeah well what would USA
do if they found that though we've
purchased pretty vigorously protest did
you say
would they protest with their drones or
they're all are you such as now come to
Britain I would kill 700 Brits but would
they be walk let me get this right
Britain once again bravo Bravo one
second Britain sells weapons to the
enemy of America and America's just
gonna say we're gonna do a protest
Britain why because we have law
we're not primitive like Islamic
societies we have the world ready is
that why our government Iraq and killed
1 million in this amendment
oh you're right like you they make you
they saw how ignorant can you be a lot
of statistics show 1 million when she's
attack each other that's not my issue
can you imagine this in in Iraq Sunnis
and Shias killed each other this is what
you are bringing first Tommy Robinson I
see spokesman you guys you guys are so
many comment you all believe is
something most terrorism and then the
bridge like these two lovely people here
and myself we okay Irish UK UK Irish
okay we are innocent people
we are the innocent people who are being
killed by Islamic extremists and
far-right extremists we are the ones
that suffer people like you your hands
hungry far-right extremist to killing
people oh okay alright let's get into
that low Kooks is a killer do you know
what he shouted before when he was gonna
do Safari killer no I just wanted you
didn't you gave me one person oh sorry
sorry he wants more support yes one
place like London Bridge well complicit
more like Westminster Bridge attend
multiple people - if he's Reebok yes
that was true why we're getting at the
motive for that person but yes how many
people killed one person was killed I
agree I mean Iran
sorry I mean you'll run over I had no
waiting
are you crazy far-right extremism with
his own maturity the resume said that
yes I do what's wrong terrorism go hand
in hand because promoters
I would you just asked me a question
show me one far-right extreme terrorism
Joe cooks his killer okay Ally okay Ally
show me one person that runs over people
Finsbury Park okay I'll be okay Ally two
people dying to show me this is this is
my channel show me one verse from the
Quran the head of this then [ __ ] oh
this has got two innocent people
why is it that we were told one mi5 is
cop is trying to track twenty thousand
extremists in this country the Muslim
extremists you grew up he wants to
create what a create main in our society
why they're actively monitoring three
thousand but they in twenty thirty
thousand people support I said well the
one look number one I said when he ran
away worker one Muslims World War II
Muslims Nagasaki was this Hiroshima
Muslims Africa straight raised Muslims
Stalin Stalin killing 50 million people
white
Muslim Mao Zedong seventy million people
wipe Muslim history Muslim pest I look
like a Muslim is that Muslim what about
him and him wasn't it and him and this
guy look at this in American media every
day you have a mass shooting you have a
mass shooting so when these people are
challenged what they do three times you
run away over they run away over he runs
away you're gonna run away a lot my
mates my friend you're gonna you get
used to it start joking you're gonna run
away alone one of your friend or emotion
I walked away through the what's going
winter wonderland so probably going one
of the rights yeah okay cause he didn't
like this right here this one was a bit
too fast for him for the exposing
challenge the cowards when you get
smoking will go one ha is too much and
he runs off